have you heard about this squid game
coin get out of here squid game coin
squid game coin yeah you have the story
so there's there was a scam a crypto
scam in the
crypto world based around this squid
game coin so the biggest show on netflix
possibly in the history of netflix is
the squid game right washington post um
this is um
wherever you found it
um
so basically quid the squid game crypto
coin
plunges to zero after scammers steal
millions of dollars from investors okay
this is our absolute ridiculous
story so basically you know we're all
familiar with this story this
netflix show called squid game it's a
korean show where basically people have
to commit um
basically play games in order to survive
or pay off their debt or make money i've
never seen the show quite frankly
i've heard about it
um so basically someone decided hey you
know what
let's roll with the with the fad let's
create a digital token
around the squid game yeah and they call
it the squid game coin aka squid coin so
basically
um they created this currency and it
surged to a high of 2 800 a coin what
and then the rug was pulled out from
investors and it crumbled all the way
down to zero squid gang coin down to
zero from 2800 bucks down to zero now
are you investing in squid game coins is
that something that you would do so
basically the creators they they got in
they pumped and dumped they pulled the
rug out and they cashed out and they
stole over two million dollars the
article yeah the article i have here
it's not the same one you have but it's
three point three okay a million three
point three this particle says two
million so maybe it's been more yeah
well over two million yeah
wow wow wow wow yeah so people were said
you know this is called getting up in
fad investing
right you're just buying the fad and
people are basically saying look and
there were certain red flags that were
happening over this apparently the
website that was up is now gone
apparently there were spelling errors
all over this website well it wasn't
unprofessed in that it's like yeah and
here's the catch investors could only
buy but they could not sell squid coin
you can only get in we couldn't get out
wow so you're
so
this is the
definition
on trying to get rich quick this is the
definition of jumping on trends to make
a quick buck so no one made any money
this never works out well no the the
three million bucks that these those
scammers came out yeah but they made
money but no everyone lost money it's
down to zero so you couldn't where did
they trade this on a special website not
i don't know i don't know what platform
where they were on but no i don't think
it was on robin hood it was on their
website apparently who what i mean come
on exactly so
the problem with crypto is that it's
taken there's the good there's the
bitcoin there's ethereum i get it solana
cordano there's things that are legit
right yeah and then there's this
nonsense yeah and you know who's super
happy about this nonsense happening
this guy right here if you lost money on
squid game coin yeah
you only have yourself to blame yeah i
do you only have yourself i am very
happy that people lost money
on squid coin okay yeah because it's a
crypto has removed all sensibilities in
reality from money i'm just buying a
squid coin and i'm a millionaire i want
to get the next bitcoin as the mentality
exactly so
um it makes me happy
that you maybe you've learned a lesson
that you're not just gonna try to get
rich quick on a squid coin or when game
of thrones coins come out or breaking
bad coin comes out or tiger king coin
comes out you're not just gonna jump on
and try to get rich quick because you
learned a lesson from squid coin
okay you got in i feel bad for the
person that got in at 2800 bucks a coin
now it's down to zero squid coin how
about that for you
you know i think the whole thing with
squid coin is basically you can't pay
off your debts and you're basically uh a
burden on society and there's no way
that you can succeed so you compete in
this game to basically win money and
basically free your life
that's basically what happened here you
get caught up in a scam and now
basically your financial life or this
financial crypto life
got cut off dude that's mind-blowing
poor i mean i don't know if i feel do
you feel bad for these people because i
think cause it's like at one point it's
like dude come on if you invested in
like a weird website with a bunch of
spelling mistakes and you thought it was
legit
and it's not like on robin hood or like
come on you kind of yeah you shot
yourself you asked for this bro
and i'm sorry you lost 200 bucks that
sucks but like like you said at least
dude at least now you know but like i
feel like you should have known you
should have known
investing in squid coins anyway
so the next time that someone approaches
you with a ridiculous idea like not
everything is going to make money all
right so when tiger king coin comes out
take a pass yeah well this is like a
good time to announce do your
announcement we have the sauce coin
coming up uh it's gonna
it's um
it's gonna be available soon but check
out www.sauce.uk
yes
well played david
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken